we all make mistakes albeit some can be
worse than others but we often have the
opportunity to learn from our mistakes
and to not make them again in the future
but what about ourselves do they make
mistakes
well yes they too make mistakes all the
time actually
and i suppose over the many years of
evolution they've had the chance to
rectify those mistakes
as if those mistakes reduce their
fitness they'd be less likely to survive
so hello and welcome to the chicky
science show where in this video we're
going to look at mistakes in the context
of protein synthesis and how improving
the accuracy of protein synthesis was
able to improve the lifespan of yeast
one man flies and therefore shows
potential as a longevity target so in
this video you'll first understand what
mistakes can occur during protein
synthesis then we'll take a look at this
recent publication and how they
identified a genetic mutation that
improved the accuracy of translation and
lastly what future studies could be used
given this information to improve the
accuracy of protein synthesis also
providing longevity benefits
now when most people think about
cellular mistakes they talk about dna
mutations mistakes made during dna
replication which yes they can happen
but actually an even more erroneous
stage of gene expression that is going
from gene to protein product is the
translation of the rna sequence into
protein
the process of translation
and well when i say erroneous the
frequency of translation mistakes is on
the order of 10 to the minus 3 to 10 to
the minus 6. now that may sound low or
not but it's still much higher than for
dna mutations which are estimated at 1.4
times 10 to the minus 8 for nucleotide
sites in humans
so what ramifications does a mistake in
translation have well translation is the
process whereby triplets of the mrna
sequence
are read and the corresponding amino
acids is brought into the machinery
complex
and joined together to form a chain of
amino acids which form the protein
so a mistake would be incorporating the
incorrect amino acid into the protein
chain but that's only one amino acid in
a protein chain does that have any
influence
well take the protein p43 for example
the world's coolest protein
you thought i'd forgotten if a mistake
happens in the production of p53 it
could end up doing the wrong thing
because the changes in the amino acid
sequence may influence how the protein
folds or it might affect the activity of
the protein and may not be able to
perform its function in the same way
but you know one mistake on one protein
out of hundreds of that same protein
within a cell it's probably gonna be
okay but what if mistakes keep happening
what if the accuracy of protein
synthesis declines over time could this
be an explanation for the aging process
well it could well be
loss of accuracy and translation comes
under the umbrella of the hallmark of
aging term loss of proteostasis
which broadly refers to the loss of the
ability to maintain correctly folded and
functional proteins in a cell over time
and so far most of the evidence for
supporting a connection between
translational fidelity and aging has
come from single-celled organisms like
yeast
whereby mutations in the ribosome
complex that carries out translation
protein synthesis whereby they become
more error-prone it shortens the
chronological lifespan of the yeast and
so given that proteins are kind of
ubiquitously synthesized within a cell
the ribosome has a bit of a mammoth
challenge on its hands to be able to
accurately synthesize all these proteins
and the ribosome itself is a complex
machinery composed of both protein and
rna and the process of protein synthesis
is a highly energetic one and it's
thought that this energetic process is
coupled to rearrangements within the
ribosome complex to actually try and
enhance the fidelity of protein
synthesis
and that's all due to interactions
between the codons from the mrna
sequence with trna transfer rnas that
carry in each individual amino acids
and so mutations within the ribosome
itself whether it's on the rna
components or the protein components may
alter the structure and dynamics of the
ribosome and therefore influence how the
sequence is read and therefore could
influence the accuracy of translation
so that was probably a bit tmi i mean i
had like three lectures on this as
undergrad so i didn't expect you to
fully understand
but let's take a look at some of the
data from this paper as i think it will
help to make a bit more sense
so what they did first in the study was
perform an unbiased phylogenetic
analysis so basically looking at the
sequences of different ribosome
components across different organisms to
see which ones are conserved in
evolution
as if it's conserved there's likely a
reason for that that is the residue is
important
and so what you're looking at now is
part of the structure of the ribosome
whereby you can see the mrna sequence
that's being read by the ribosome and a
trna one of these transfer rnas that is
going to be bringing in one of the amino
acids to add to the protein gene and
what's indicated in this structure is a
protein component of the ribosome known
as rps23
and the reason we're looking at rps23
is because if you compare the sequences
of this protein from archaea
all the way through to eukaryotes like
us
consistently they found in their
analysis a lysine residue so lysine is
an amino acid consult in a specific
region of this protein so it was nearly
invariant throughout evolution
now i emphasized the word nearly because
there were some exceptions to this rule
where instead of having a lysine residue
they had an arginine residue
and the exceptions were hypothermophilic
archaea and what that means is that
these archaea predominantly are living
in extreme conditions such as high
temperature and acidic environments and
that metabolized sulfur so not somewhere
you'd want to be
anyway the authors of the study thought
this was very interesting and decided to
see what happens if you change this
lysine residue to an arginine and the
implications for protein synthesis
so using a very clever reporter assay
they did this in flies whereby they'd
given these flies to mutation so that
they now had arginine in this rps23
protein instead of lysine and what they
found was that the accuracy of protein
synthesis improved and this improvement
was even seen in older flies as well
where normally you would see a much
greater increase in the amount of errors
made in translation
now this phrase is a very interesting
question if this mutation was improving
the accuracy of protein synthesis
why didn't evolution select for this
mutation
well one hypothesis is the fact that
accuracy is kind of in a trade-off with
speed whereby the more accurate the
process is the slower it takes to
actually produce a protein and so if
you're producing a lot of proteins that
could have downtown consequences of a
reduced growth in the organism which
makes it less competitive
whilst if you want to improve the rate
of protein synthesis it might lose
accuracy as a cost but what the authors
found was that it didn't really seem to
impair the global translation
instead they found in yeast worms and
flies that the presence of this mutation
delayed their development for example in
one of the species of yeast those that
had the mutation
formed smaller colonies and showed
growth retardation in liquid media
on the flip side the yeast flies and
worms that they tested with this
mutation shows heat stress resistance
and so the authors rationalize that the
developmental data explains the presence
of the arginine residue in organisms
that live only in extreme conditions for
which increased translation fidelity is
a strong selective pressure
so that explains why we might not have
this mutation but would having the
mutation be better in a long run for
lifespan
well as you can see here in the yeast
worms and flies that they tested with
this mutation they showed lifespan
extensions mediated by the single change
from nine percent to 23 percent
and so this suggested that this improved
accuracy in the translation provides a
potential novel anti-aging intervention
but are there non-genetic ways of being
able to improve the accuracy of
translation well if you watch my videos
you've probably heard of the compound
rapamycin that inhibits the protein the
mammalian target of rapamycin mtor
and mtor does many many things in a cell
but one of the things that regulates is
translation itself
whereby increased amateur activity has
been shown to improve the rates of
translation
and so a study came out a couple of
years ago that i made a blog on
in the study they showed that by slowing
down the rate of translation it improved
the fidelity of translation so it
improved the accuracy and so this goes
back to that kind of trade-off that i
was talking about earlier so what the
authors tested next was whether or not
they could see similar effects on the
the accuracy of translation
with rapamycin and similar molecules
and whether there would be a synergistic
improvement on accuracy if you combined
rapamycin with this arginine mutation
and well you can see the data here and
basically as before those organisms that
had the rgb mutation live longer
but adding rypomitin only seemed to show
additional benefit in the drosophila to
the flies
but these additional increases were
modest and so basically what this
suggests is that when translation
accuracy is increased the capacity of
rapamycin to extend lifespan is likely
limited to its remaining
organism-specific anti-aging components
basically referring to the fact that
maybe most of the impacts of rapamycin
is due to its improvements on protein
accuracy
and so whilst it remains to be seen
whether these hyper-accurate ribosomal
mutations are beneficial in mammals it
argues for screening of compounds with
the potential to reduce protein errors
during aging
as a pharmaceutical target
especially in the case of
neurodegenerative diseases that are
primarily affected by the deterioration
of proteostasis
and the spark also helps us to further
understand how rapamycin may be
mediating its anti-aging benefits that
are seen in different organisms and
while it will be very interesting to see
the results of the pole study that's
asserting grapomycin in human clinical
trials
so with that i hope you've enjoyed this
video on protein fidelity thank you to
my patreon supporters and thank you for
listening